III 2014 I'm your host on your wire and
I'm joined by Joe Albertson how you
doing hey deal my friends dubstep yes
it's the one thing everyone's been
saying it's just there's not enough
video games computer games have dubstep
but it's not enough games which are
entirely based around dubstep and that's
how I started was brainstorm session
really make a game about dubstep and
everyone went wild and then we moved on
talked about some other games and we
actually picked a different game I
remember what it was because I looked
around the room I said screw it we're
doing the dubstep one everyone like ya
dope bores yeah you guys does I've seen
the steam page you're on early access at
the moment as well right now we just got
approval and so we're looking at
Friday's when we're gonna launch
excellent oh wow really yeah early it's
Friday Friday
III special yeah well that's it all
right so we're looking at the gameplay
here and for folks at home explain what
the boors is okay so the way it works is
instead of being an arcade shooter where
you just mash the button and just fire
and shoot everything
the weapons actually control are
controlled by the music so if it's a
really heavy part the bass drops and you
get these big giant lasers if there's
nothing it's a little melody you're
running for your life so that's the
strategy awesome so like so it's instead
of picking the different weapons you
want to fire at any one time it's kind
of up to the song correct and so weak
cuts to build everything around the
music and so a new song means all new
weapons a whole new experience
excellence all right let's hop into a
level so we can we can see some of it
here so this inner doctor he's gonna get
you started a couple things coming out
at you and we actually go through and
pick which sounds we want to put some
the player weapons and then eventually
we'll have some that'll be the
background enemy movement oh wow we're
really trying to integrate the music
into the gameplay as much as we can are
you guys writing the music as well then
no I'm licensing everything Oh excellent
yeah we we spend a lot of time combing
the internet you know the dubstep that's
gonna work there's not yeah I imagine if
you go deep enough there's quite a lot
of people just making dubstep I love it
oh yes chucking it up there I mean
that's a famous game is you type dubstep
in a word and see what comes up and
there's usually 99% of time you'll find
a hit so I guess knowing the songs is
obviously a benefit
like making sure you're in the right
position for the right weapon and all
right guys so that's the strategy of it
is as you learn the song you know when
the big lasers coming up or window boy
then you can start Titan enemies and
survive and one let the folks at home
noted if you have any questions for Joe
at Donnie underwire on Twitter I'm also
looking at the GameSpot shot as well so
you have any questions for Joe by all
means send them in and so how big is
Mora how many of you guys are actually
working on this so right now there's
about nine of it so yeah we've got a
decent sized team and growing and we're
actually like I can make those effects
amazing then absolutely hit us up
looking pretty sharp at the moment you
guys doing this in your spare time that
the effects part yeah we've actually
been covering because we don't have a
solid person into that position all
right
female me and I'll send it on and I'll
get my commission
yeah there we go how many songs you're
gonna have in the game like it's kind of
an interesting thing where a song is a
mission right or some level of like
Luminess or something like that
so the early access panda will have five
songs and then we've licensed ten so
we're working as fast as we can to start
putting in the next level and so as
we're pumping out new levels will be
polishing the game you know all the way
through launch and then after that
what's great about being each levels a
song is DLC is just unlimited oh yeah of
course yeah yeah yeah this thing could
extend out for a long time I'm sure it's
probably incredibly difficult but what
comes to mind as well as something like
audiosurf there's no way of just having
it so you can import your own dubstep
and music gets play right so we decided
to really hone the experience and custom
do everything and so we put a lot of
love into each level to make sure that
you know the weapons are there
and instead of just reading an mp3 of
anything you know jamming to Britney
Spears or whatever yeah we're really
saying no we want the right dubstep
music and we're gonna make everything to
be a really fun experience to WX is
asking what platforms this game is on so
we're looking at the PC version there
were you guys looking at consoles as
well so we've got the beta on the whoo
you ain't on soul and then we're
launching on Steam for PC and Mac and
then we're gonna get Linux support up as
soon as we can actually and then from
there other platforms we're looking at
you know consoles so put it on a ps4
yeah Xbox one Wii U and then also mobile
so it's really about we want to find the
experience for mobile what do you do
virtual joysticks touch controls so
until we figure that out we want to make
sure that it's a fun experience and then
we'll launch that's cool Italy you seem
like you're approaching it responsibly
and not fighting off too much you know
more than you can chew or like all right
what about the folks who have made the
songs because in my head I'm imagining a
bunch of people around the world who
have made dubstep who are like trying to
find an audience who's making good music
you can make good music enough nobody
ever listened to it right like is it
what's the reaction from people you him
helped there we go
you know making this twin-stick shooter
you want to put your song in this game
actually the first one that we put in
this guy didn't even have a license yet
yeah he's living at home you know make
it to dubstep and we had a connection
through one of our artists reached out
to them and we put him in the game and
so that's been a lot of fun so it's
really about you know yeah we wanted
some more established artists we're
absolutely gonna roll that way but you
know there's some of these guys that are
following us on Twitter and I'll send
them a message they'll be like hey I
just listen to soundcloud like I'm
interested people I already know
pitching you songs Dennison yeah
absolutely absolutely have you had a
situation where somebody's made a song
specifically so the pacing of the game
like how are you working with them on
that or are you using songs and then as
level designers and game designers
trying to craft a good experience around
so starting now we've been thinking
established
because one of our prototypes was
actually taking dubstep elements and
trying to mix it together and we found
this so instead of altering the music
we're trying to custom build it we want
a finished song that people enjoy they
can listen to on repeat yeah and then
we'll build around that so there
eventually will be some artists I think
that will write specifically for our
game but you know the same same rules
apply if it doesn't fit then we can't
use it that's interesting because I
guess like one of the things that people
may perhaps people who aren't very
familiar with dubstep as a wider genre
would say that it's pretty intense so if
you're trying to make a game where you
want somebody to sit down and play for a
while yeah like maybe blaring dubstep in
their ear holes it's not the best way of
doing it how do you kind of throttle
about how do you make sure that the
music is impactful but without being
just overwhelming so those are some
things that we look for if it's got a
good melody you know and it's not just
just non-stop yeah and we we avoid that
stuff because it is too much it's very
taxing and that's kind of our test is if
we can design to it and listen to it
continuously and then players should be
able to do the same I do you have levels
then that are longer because the songs
are longer yeah we're looking at three
to five minutes and you know we kind of
want to stick with in that timeframe but
if we get a really good song with six
minutes or one that's 2 minutes then
we'll build that and put that in there
am i right in saying that this I think I
remember seeing this as a Kickstarter as
well right yeah we did a small
Kickstarter to kind of get things
started like last summer yeah yeah and
so it's kind of been a pretty long
process just licensing the music it's
been nine months you know so some of
these publishers bless their heart are
very difficult to push things through
it's pretty like the music industry as
archaic as the games industry can be
sometimes about licensing and copyright
and stuff the music industry is
ahead of a mess of you a Denis and like
dubsteps pretty big in Japan as well
their music licensing stuff is an
absolute nightmare is it mostly North
American stuff or so that's actually
suddenly we were looking forward to is
once we establish the market here then
we're gonna reach out and filled you
know music for South Korea or China or
Japan he's their artist and then
actually outsource so that you know the
backgrounds all fit with our culture let
me talk a little bit about the
Kickstarter as well like the hike on
what you created it seems to be like a
game that is very could be has the
potential to be very fun and engaging
but it also like just a hook of its the
idea that this is a game based around
like you firing off dubstep and then the
name as well yeah it's kind of like I
don't know it's immediately recognizable
and kind of funny yeah and with the
Kickstarter do you think the people who
were investing we're doing so just
because that sounds like a dumb idea
sure we're throwing money in or are they
sort of engaged in the project we
actually didn't launch our Kickstarter
time we had a playable demo ok so that
really helps a lot because we've kind of
got that fun factor we're three seconds
we're hooking a lot of people yeah and
some of the comments we hear like I hate
dubstep and then they play it they're
like I love dubstep yeah so we're really
taking the music and getting the most
out of it spent a lot of fun yeah
and so how long have you been working on
this then if it was you already on a
demo way before you even did your
Kickstarter um so we started last
January and you know the team size has
been as biggest 9 and as small as just
one yeah so there was a while I was just
working on this myself so it actually
started Utah Valley University so I was
kind of a college project that I spun
off and we're pushing it commercial
awesome so when can people actually get
to play double wars so Friday Friday
will be on Steam and we're gonna be
launching I want to say 12 o'clock okay
Pacific time so yeah we'll get it out as
early as we can and get people playing
it sweet you got to go home and make
sure you've got all those support emails
yeah ready to like a bunch of pre typing
emails and everything awesome Joe
pleasure thank you so much for coming on
the stage and showing her stuff wars yes
a luck with the launch on Friday as well
thank you cool